audition naturellement avec le président
Lafond dans le cadre des travaux que
nous avons décidés au printemps dernier
et nous accueillons aujourd'hui madame
Michel paatti madame merci de de votre
présence je vous rappelle à chacun et
chacune d'entre vous que cette audition
est publique à savoir qu'elle est
retransmise sur les réseau du Sénat mais
également ouverte au public à la presse
et à tous ceux qui s'intéresse à nos
travaux nous avons prévu 1h30 d'horloge
à peu près
et donc chacun pourra évidemment
s'exprimer s'il le souhaite après que
nous ayons pu entendre madame paaty je
voudrais peut-être rappeler avant de
laisser la parole au président Lafond
que il y a seulement 4 jours au lycée
Gambetta d'aras Dominique Bernard
professeur de lettrre a été assassiné
professeur d'éducation physique et
sportive un agent d'entretien et le chef
d'équipe technique de l'établissement
ont également été blessés tous tentaient
de protéger leurs collègues et leurs
élèves contre un assaillant dont les
motivations islamistes ne font plus de
doute ou ne font guerre de doute cet
attentat entendait-il entendait
semble-t-il prolongé celui survenu il y
a 3 ans qui a conduit à l'assassinat de
Monsieur Samuel
pati cet attentat vient ainsi
cruellement illustrer l'actualité de de
la question que nos deux commissions ont
souhaité traiter la commission des
affaires culturelles de l'éducation et
des sport ainsi que la commission des
lois de manière commune en créant cette
mission de contrôle
pour contrôler le traitement les
signalements et le traitement des
pressions et les pressions pardon qui
sont menaces et agressions dans les
enseignants sont victimes
pardon nous entendons madame nous
entendons aujourd'hui vous êtes la sœur
de Monsieur Samuel pati vous aviez je le
rappelle ici adressé un courrier au
président du Sénat lequel président du
Sénat et à moi-même d'ailleurs et nous
avons décidé avec le président Lafond de
mettre en place cette mission not
trudition était prévu de longue date je
le redis qu'elle est transmise en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et je vous
remercie d'avoir accepté de témoigner
devant nous j'ai néanmoins déjà eu
l'occasion de le préciser lors de nos
auditions de cet été et c'est important
pour que chacun et chacune d'entre nous
mesure bien la portée de notre travail
cette mission d'information ne peut se
pencher sur des faits qui font l'objet
d'une enquête en cours j'insiste si tel
était le cas évidemment mission
prendrait fin immédiatement
naturellement
elle a vocation à se pencher en revanche
sur les mécanismes devant permettre de
prévenir l'occurrence de tel DRAM à
l'avenir malheureusement bien sûr nous
venons de le revivre trop récemment
notamment l'évaluation et le traitement
des
menaces dans ce cadre votre témoignage
madame évidemment sur ce qui s'est passé
il y a 3 ans et qui reste dans nos
mémoires est absolument essentiel je
vais laisser la parole au président
Lafond et à la fin de son son
intervention parce que nous sommes sous
forme de commission
d'enquête je devrais vous demander de
prêter serement mais je vais d'abord
laisser le président de la fond le
président la fond la parole merci mes
chers collègues comme vient de le
souligner le président buffet cette
audition s'inscrit dans un contexte
pesant le le drame qui s'est déroulé
dans l'enceinte du lycée Gambetta d'aras
est venu bratellement nous nous rappeler
la menace que font planer
l'obscurantisme et et le
sur nos sociétés il nous rappelle
également que les écoles lieu de
transmission de savoir et de formation à
la citoyenneté sont devenus une cible
pour les inchristes islamistes avant de
débuter cette audition nous avons bien
entendu une pensée pour Dominique
Bernard lâchement assassiné pour sa
famille ses proches ainsi que pour les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale
blessé vendredi à ras nous tenons aussi
à vous remercier Madame Paty d'avoir
accepté de venir témoigner devant nos
commissions au moment où cet assassinat
ravive des souvenirs douloureux pour
l'ensemble de la communauté éducative et
bien sûr pour vous-même vos différentes
prises de paroles ont été scrutées et
commenté depuis l'assassinat de votre
frère hier vous êtes intervenu 3 ans
jour pour jour après le drame au sein du
collège François Girou à Vincenne et sur
la scène du théâtre de l'œuvre pour
prononcer des mots particulièrement
poignants certaines de de vos sorties se
sont avéré tristement
prémonitoires comme lorsque vous
déclariez il y a 15 jours dans Marianne
que nous n'étions pas dans l'après
Samuel pati mais dans le pendant
d'autres raisonnent avec une acuité
toute particulière comme lorsque vous
déclariez à l'occasion de la remise d'un
prix créé enhonneur de votre frère
qu'enseignz c'est expliqué et non se
taire je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui un
enseignant sur deux déclare dans notre
pays autocensuré par peur de
contestation d'enseignement c'est dans
ce contexte que nous conduisons cette
mission commune de contrôle destiné non
pas à juger des faits tâche qui relève
comme l'a rappelé le président buffet de
procédure judiciaire en cours mais à les
comprendre à les mettre en perspective
et à apprécier également si la situation
a évolué depuis 3 ans afin de formuler
évidemment des propositions visant à
améliorer la réactivité et l'efficacité
des services publics concerné qu'il
s'agisse de la police de la justice ou
de l'éducation nationale nous essayons à
notre tour et dans notre rôle
d'expliquer et de ne pas nous taire pour
prévenir non plus l'occurrence mais la
multiplication des drames nous allons
donc vous écouter attentivement dans
quelques instants madame Paty non sans
vous avoir préalablement informé comme
l'a fait le président buffet que cette
audition est diffusée en direct sur le
site du
Sénat bien euh je voudrais rappeler aux
collègues donc je vous ai indiqué qu'on
avait 1h30 on peut jusqu'à 2h hein nous
sommes nombreux bien sûr les prises de
parole doivent être signalées pour qu'on
puisse les enregistrer et se partager
entre la commission des lois et la
commission de l'éducation naturellement
et nous limitons le temps d'intervention
à 2 minutes si on veut que tout le monde
puisse pouvoir puisse s'exprimer
naturellement avant de passer la parole
madame je dois vous rappeler que nous
nous sommes dotés des pouvoirs de
commission d'enquête et qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues par les dispositions des
articles
434-13-1 et- 15 du code pénal je vous
invite à prêter serment de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité et je vous
invite donc à lever la main droite et de
dire je le jure je le jure merci Madame
et bien vous avez la parole et nous vous
écoutons je dédie ce texte à Monsieur
Dominique Bernard professeur assassiné
ce vendredi 13 octobre 2023 lors d'une
attaque terroriste islamique mettant à
exécution les ordres de ceux qui veulent
détruire notre école pour détruire notre
démocratie oui je dédie ce texte à celui
qu'on n pas sauvé Monsieur Dominique
Bernard Messieurs les Présidents Françis
Noël buffet et Laurent Laffond mesdames
et messieurs les
sénateurs je viens tout d'abord vous
remercier pour l'ouverture de cette
mission de contrôle parlementaire dotée
des pouvoirs de commission d'enquête
afin de comprendre les failles
administratives et politiques qui ont pu
concourir à l'assassinat de Samuel pati
d'analyser les mesures correctives qui
en ont découlé et d' tirer les évidentes
recommandations en voulant vous écrire
ces quelques mots je me suis retrouvé
face à l'angoisse de la page blanche et
j'ai compris qu'en fait cette angoisse
ne vient pas que l'on ait rien à dire
mais au contraire de ce qu'il y a trop à
dire je me suis ensuite perdu dans les
méandres du politiquement correct ou à
trop mettre les formes on en oublie le
fond il a fallu revenir à l'essentiel je
dirais même aux fondamentaux le simple
fait qu'un professeur ait pu être
décapité pour blasphème en France en
2020 démontre que faille il y
a cette enquête je vous ai demandé de l'
menener au nom de Samuel paatti mon
frère il faut partir du singulier pour
comprendre ce qui nous regarde tous car
partir de tous ne nous perra jamais de
comprendre le destin tragique d'un homme
d'un professeur mon frère Samuel paatti
je viens effectivement vous presser
d'investiguer bien au-delà du cercle
imputabilité définie par la justice la
justice traite le crime en fonction du
champ des possibles mais la vérité
judiciaire ne condamne que ce qui est
pénalement répréhensible et néglige la
responsabilité politique celle qui prône
le respect des droits fondamentaux
l'ordre républicain et l'intérêt commun
cette vérité et réalité dont je vous
parle est celle qui est mise entre
guillemets et minimisée par tous ceux
qui se retrouvaient face à leur
responsabilité s'ils devaient
l'affronter sans phare ce comportement
d'irresponsabilité illimité est légitimé
par une meute de courtisans prêt à tout
les compromissions en délivrant des
certificats de probité sans examen de
conscience il est également encouragé
par l'attribution de promotion et de
décoration même s'il a Liu échec ou
fiasco ce qui donne le sentiment à ceux
qui les reçoivent d'avoir fait ce qui
doit être fait et procure une unité de
fait à ceux qui les distribuent les
inconséquences qui en découlent
renforcent la méfiance et la défiance
d'un peuple qui ne recroit plus en ses
représentants ce renoncement à
l'intégrité non par incapacité
intellectuelle ne permet plus de mettre
en harmonie la parole et les actes il
n'y a plus que cette probité de façade
qui laisse ouvertes des brèches immenses
permettant la réalisation des actes les
plus odieux c'est bien ce contexte là
que l'absurde est devenu réalité mon
frère a été décapité le 16 octobre 2020
3 ans après il est temps de réaliser que
la fameuse phrase lancée par Monsieur
Blanquer il y aura un avant et un après
Samuel paatti n'a pas eu les effets
attendus c'est après qui laisse régner
la violence pour clore tout débat et
ainsi Infiné imposer le respect des
croyances et non plus des croyants
basculant ainsi d'une démocratie laïque
à une théocratie le baillon est
définitivement obtenu en adjectivant le
mot laïcité afin d'en dénaturer le sens
et de la transformer en une injonction à
l'athéisme si la référence n'est plus la
loi mais le fait de ne pas offenser
certains musulmans qui mettent leur
créateur au-dessus de tout de la justice
comme de la fraternité cela n'entraînera
que censure et immanquablement une
application différenciée des règles en
fonction de l'appartenance religieuse
octroyant finalement plus de droit à
certains véritable ferment de discorde
et de
séparatisme prenez la tolérance et
invoquez toujours plus de bienveillance
sous-entendant ainsi que le professeur
pourra être malveillante par nature n'a
pourtant ouvert la voie qu'à des dérives
incontrôlables et finalement au
renforcement des extrêmes face à
l'efficacité il faut peut-être cesser de
dire que c'est le résultat qui est
erronné et bien plutôt de reconnaître
que c'est la méthode qui est
mauvaise je vous invite à essayer de
mettre le mot empathie à la place de
bienveillance juste essayer en adoptant
la perspective d'autrui la culture de
l'empathie favorise la lutte contre
leharcèlement comme monsieur hatal a pu
le dire les le mois dernier mais pour
répondre au détracteurs de cette idée
cela ne se résume pas à cela cette
attitude favorise également un climat
scolaire propice aux apprentissages
conforte le le respect de la pluralité
des opinions et permet de se prévenir
des pensées dogmatiques il y a plusieurs
forme d'empathie l'empathie émotionnelle
est la seule capable d'induire un
comportement moral c'est celle qu'a
utilisé dans le cours de mon frère la
notion de bien et de mal est le plus
souvent acquise ce qui manque
cruellement c'est de reconnaître
émotionnellement les préjudices ou
douleurs causées ce qu'on appelle la
responsabilité morale d'ailleurs le
Danemark l'a bien compris puisque les
cours d'empathie ils sont obligatoires
depuis une loi de
1993 donc de 6 à 16 ans ils reçoivent 1
heure d'empathie par semaine et ces
enfants ont la chance d'accès à ses
cours pour leur bien-être et le
bien-être de tous sans sympathie sans
cette capacité il est impossible de
comprendre les principes de la laïcité
et les valeurs de la République ni même
celle de la liberté d'expression sans
impathie on acccorde aucun crédit à la
vie de l'autre l'autre étant relégué au
rang d'ennemis ce n'est pas nécessement
le contenu des réseaux sociaux qui pose
un problème mais bien la culture de la
tête baissée qui nous ferme au monde par
un repli narcissique et nous empêche de
dépasser la peur de l'inconnu l'empathie
permet de rétablir qui est victime et
qui est bourreau et non d'avoir à se
confronter avec des bourreaux
prétendument victime car c'est
ainsi excusez-moi qu'on finit avec des
qu'on finit avec des crimes sans
coupable voire avec des victime un peu
responsable l'éducation à l'empathie
restaure le sens du mot fraternité je
citerai monsieur Omar Zana docteur en
sociologie et en psychologie professeur
des université en sciences de
l'éducation au l'empathie cela séduque
certes la disposition à l'empathie est
inérante à l'espèce humaine mais si elle
n'est pas éduquée elle ne se développe
pas je pense également qu'il serait sal
que parents et personnel à tout niveau
de l'institution en bénéficie
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on devient après ça
c'est bien cette question que je me suis
posé le lendemain de sa mort il bien
falloir que j'en fasse quelque chose de
ce s un S sans nom juste un visuel à
l'Institut médico légal où ma réaction
première a été de dire ce n'est pas lui
je crois que je voulais pas que ce corp
meurtri soit celui de mon frère ce ça
inomable ne prendrait sens que lorsque
j'aurais eu toutes les vérités même cell
dont je n'aurais pas voulu qu'ell soit
vraie en règle générale nous choisissons
nos vérités mais dans certains cas on
observe que c'est pas nous qui
choisissons nos vérités mais ce sont les
vérités qui nous choisissent c'est ce
qui se passe quand certains veulent nous
imposer leur vérité celles qui sont
agréables et rassurantes pour eux pas
pour
moi je crois que c'est ce qui s'est
passé le 3 décembre 2020 à la lecture du
rapport de l'inspection générale de
l'éducation du sport et de la Recherche
ce rapport s'intitule avec une sobriété
forcée et anonyme enquête sur les
événements survenus au collège du bois
d'Ô Conflant saintonorine retirant à mon
frère la plus simple dignité celle que
cette enquête soit menée en son nom ici
on parle de gérer un trouble l' Régine
du trouble étant le cours sur la liberté
d'expression de Samuel Patier la
formulation choisie trahit l'intention
véritable de ce travail il s'agit non de
faire la lumière sur les responsabilité
les éventuelles erreurs des uns et des
autres dans cette affaire mais avant
tout de dédoiner l'institution de toute
responsabilité éventuelle on
s'interrogera sur la conception très
particulière du dialogue que cette
mission inspection a pu avoir avec les
acteurs du terrain seul trois
professeurs sur ont été entendus sur les
51 qui composent l'équipe pédagogique
vers versus quatre représentants des
parents d'élèves inversant ainsi le
rapport de force on pourrait également
s'interroger sur la rapidité de sa
rédaction le rapport ayant été bouclé ou
bâlé en 15 jours ce qui ne laisse
d'interroger sur le but attendu je tiens
également à souligner la volonté
constante de l'éducation nationale à
travers ce rapport de faire totalement
abstraction d'une quelconque notion de
péril grave et imminent comme ce fut le
cas la semaine précédent l'attentat et
de continuer de transformer une campagne
islamique en problème pédagogique cette
procédure utilisée sans doute pour
empêcher tout exercice du droit de
retrait le cas échéant pour celui qui
oserait en tel circonstances se retirer
devenant bien évidemment un excusez-moi
un abandon de poste avec une menace de
radiation on pourrait aussi soulever les
mécanismes du N dit de l'éducation
nationale là où on parle d'élèves et de
familles compliqué jamais difficile ou
tout simplement impossible à gérer et
refusant de s'insérer dans la société
française l'administration préfère juger
que les professeurs sont en difficulté
et que les chefs d'établissement sont
insuffisant il me semble également
nécessaire d'évoquer les excuses qu'on a
demandé à Samuel de formuler auprès de
ses élèves ce comportement donne tout
pouvoir aux parents d'élèves qui ont un
compte à régler avec l'institution on se
retrouve avec des élèves victimes et
s'il n'avit pas encore pensé on les
désigne obligeamment comme tel et le
professeur devenant coupable aux yeux de
tous même de certains de ses collègues
l'un d'eux faisant du Zè pour l'accabler
se mettra en scène devant ses classes de
3e ce qui aura sur certainement motivé
ceuxci à se retrouver à 17h le 16
octobre 2020 pour livvrait mon frère à
son bourreau ce petit professeur meurtré
d'avoir perdu son titre de coordinateur
de matière au profit de mon frère il
adaptera à son tour une posture
victimaire au tour au retour des
vacances de tous sain sans doute victime
de ses collègues spectateurs complices
qui se sont inventé une conscience
post-attentat et qui pourtant ne voyent
rien à redire à son comportement avant
quand il aurait fallu resserrer les
rangs le comble viendra lorsque lui
bénéficiera de la mise en retrait
d'éducation nationale peu après la
rentrée du 2 novembre
2020 même lorsque le 9 octobre 2020 la
vérité éclatera c'est-à-dire l'absence
de la petite menteuse dans le cours
incriminé tout le monde sans exception
continuera à propager la calomnie et
traitera mon frère en coupable
l'imaginaire c'est donc substitué au
réel revenons maintenant sur le comptage
des attat Menuel à la laïcité sans doute
un terme pudique pour ne pas parler
d'offensive islamique l'ancien ministre
de l'éducation nationale monsieur
papendia pour justifier ses chiffres
préfère parler de la culture du
signalement afin de minimiser la gravité
du phénomène il précise tout de même
qu'il y aura deux pics annuels l'un
pendant le Ramadan et un autre en
octobre lié à l'attentat contre mon
frère ce qui confirme à demi-mot qu'il
s'agit bien de revendication identitaire
de la mouvance islamiste monsieur
papendia donne également le ton il
s'agit de phénomène inéluctable auquel
il faudra bien s'habituer tout en se
refusant d'admettre que nombre réel
d'atteintes à lacité est sous-évalué que
nombre de faits ne sont pas signalés et
qu'il y a une recrue d'essence depuis
l'attentat de mon frère à quoi à quoi
cela sert-il de jouer le jeu de la
transparence sans même reconnaître que
l'on nâ en nos
troubles les remontées des atteintes à
la laïcité relèvent de la responsabilité
des chefs d'établissement cell-ci sont
rédigés sur une fiche fait établissement
relevant du niveau 3 c'est-à-dire fait
d'une extrême gravité et entraîne
obligatoirement une réaction de
l'institution comme nous le montre la
fiche résumée respect du principe de la
lcité prévenir répondre soutenir il
convient de rappeler que contrairement à
ce que monsieur papendia a pu dire dans
son éudition auprès de vous le 4 juillet
dernier tous les faits de niveau 1 à 3
remontent au mystère et que le niveau 4
relève du National et ne peut donc être
prononcé au niveau académique pour les
niveaux 2 et 3 sont alertés li le
recteur les référents justice et
l'équipe mobile de sécurité pour le cas
spécifique du niveau 3 le chef
d'établissement doivent au préalable
prendre attache téléphonique auprès du
dazen ou du daazen le cas échéant avant
toute retranscription de l'événement sur
la fiche fait établissement les chefs
d'établissement se retrouvent à devoir
faire une courte narration des faits
spécifier s'il peut y avoir un
retentissement médiatique paramètre
important que je vous demande de noter
pour plus tard et remplir deux cases
victime et coupable présum
comment retire-ton l'octroit de la
protection fonctionnelle c'est assez
simple il suffit juste de remplir la
case victime par l'expression groupe
d'élèves et la case coupable par
personnel de l'établissement et ainsi c
le rend la faute personnelle imputable à
l'agent ce qui est donc un obstacle à
l'roit de la protection fonctionnelle et
même s'il en fait la demande elle lui
sera refusé document à l'appui même
cette protection dérisoire aa été
retirée à mon
frère
je m'interrogerai le je m'interroga le 9
décembre 2022 lors d'une de mes
interventions dans le cadre de la j de
la cité sur le fait qu'on laisse encore
le soin aux chefs d'établissement de
définir si tel ou telle tenu sont
ostensiblement religieuse ce
comportement n'avait pour effet que de
mettre dos à dos ceux qui les tolèrent
les gentils et ceux qui s'y opposent les
méchants les abaya les cille même le
voile affichent ostensiblement
l'appartenance religieuse islamique de
ceux qui les portent il n n'y a pas
besoin de savoir si ces tenu
vestimentairire s'accompagne de discours
ou d'attitude qui conteste la laïcité et
s'il s'agit d'un comportement prilite ou
communautariste le simple fait de les
porter est un acte de défiance vis-à-vis
de la règle commune il s'agit ni plus ni
moins d'un appel à la désobéissance
civile la règle commune est ce qui donne
la structure à une société sans
structure la société s'écroule je ne
peux que féliciter Monsieur hatal de
rejoindre mes convictions et de prendre
clairement position en renonçant avec la
practique du cas par cas qui prévalait
avant la loi de 2004
il faut arrêter de croire que ceux qui
ne respectent pas la licité n'en
comprennent pas le sens ils le
comprennent trop bien et c'est pour cela
qu' veulent la détruire le tout ce n'est
pas de parler de chantier comme l'a
martelé monsieur le Président Macron ce
24 juillet dernier avec des travaux de
rénovation coûteux pour réparer les
défauts visibles négligeant les fils
cachés et bien de définir s'il s'agit
d'un chantier de construction ou de
démolition à ce stade je voudrais
également soulever un problème qui s'est
aggravé à la suite de l'attentat contre
mon frère les enseignants quittent
massivement le navire éducation
nationale selon un rapport de la
commission des finances du Sénat sur le
budget 2022 la crise des démissions
continue de s'aggraver mettant en
évidence une péodque croissante
d'enseignants qualifiés entre 2020 et
2022 le nombre de démission est passé de
30959 à
39270 soit une augmentation de 26
%. en outre il faut ajouter les quelques
20000 départs à la retraite chaque année
qui ne sont pas remplacés intégralement
par le recrutement sur concours
cette année scolaire
2023-224 ce sont plus de 16 % des postes
au concours qui sont restés vacants soit
3100 postes non pourvu
supplémentairire la conséquence
immédiate de ces crises est l'obligation
pour le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale de faire appel à des
contractuels non formés il convient
alors de s'interroger sur les modalités
de recrutement notamment quand on sait
que Monsieur sifrioui le fichier s mis
en examen pour association de malfaiteur
terroriste criminel dans l'assassinat de
mon frère a été maître auxiliaire en
informatique pour éducation nationale
pendant 15 ans à
Paris les conséquences sont que les
enseignants restant se retrouvent avec
des classes surchargées altérant ainsi
la capacité de dispenser un enseignement
de qualité ce qui pénalisera
inévitablement en priorité les élèves
les alternatif proposé pour palier
également à l'absentéisme consiste soit
à demander aux enseignants un
fonctionnement en astreintre dans le
cadre du Pacte enseignant soit à faire
assurer par les assistants d'éducation
enseignement appelés surveillant un
cours par support numérique four par
éducation nationale comme monsieur hatal
l'a annoncé à sa nomination à son poste
actuel de ministre d'éducation nationale
tout le monde connaît l'expression qui
peut le plus peut le moins en procédure
dégradée c'est qui peut le moins fait ce
qu'il peut c'est ni la qualité ni la
pédagogie qui est attendue c'est le fait
de fournir un service minimum en mode
dégradé il y a toujours une certaine
tolérance sur les
pertes je parlerai enfin de la censure
évoquée par l'ancien ministre lui-même
plus d'un professeur sur deux ça vous sê
déjà autant censuré enquête if décembre
2022 pour reprendre ses propos il serait
y avoir d'omerta dans l'éducation
nationale et je suis intraitable à ce
sujet qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
concrètement le ministère
sanctionnerait-il celui qui n'applique
pas le programme mais quel est le
soutien de l'institution quand un
professeur relève le défi d'assurer son
programme il faut bien reconnaître que
défendre les valeurs républicaines est
bel et bien une prise de risque la
menace de se prendre une Samuel pati est
devenue une l'arme de toute censure
islamique la circulaire de l'éducation
nationale intitulé plan laïcité dans les
écoles et établissements scolaires du 9
novembre 2022 tente d'apporter une
réponse le premier volet consiste à
sanctionner systématiquement et de façon
graduée le comportement des élèves
portant atteinte à la laïcité lorsqu'il
persiste après une phase de dialogue
c'est mal connaître ces jeunes de penser
qu'un rappel à l'ordre à la loi sert à
quelque chose ce qui est perçu comme une
sanction pour éducation nationale est
perçue tout au plus comme une
humiliation aux yeux de cette jeunesse
qui n'accorde aucun crédit à l'autorité
ces sanctions qui ne débouchent sur rien
développent un sentiment d'impunité et
entraînne récidive ou vengeance on
traite les symptômes sans traiter le mal
le problème est l'absence générale
d'autorité envers cette jeunesse qui n'a
plus de limite et qui donc ni ne peut ni
ne veut faire société l'école ne peut
pas lier la carence de figure
représentant l'autorité auprès de ses
jeunes mais il faut lui rendre celle qui
lui est propre pour cela il faut que
l'institution endosse les rôles qui lui
incombent c'est-à-dire sa capacité à
prendre sous sa responsabilité les
sujets les plus plus sensible il faut
également que cette même institution
réponde du traitement erroné et de la
non protection qui en a découlé dans le
dossier de mon frère sinon pourquoi les
enseignants prendrai-ils le risque de
défendre les valeurs républicaines s'ils
ne sont pas assurés d'être protégés et
ainsi rassurer il faut restaurer une
république au comportement ferme sur ces
principes exemplaires et responsables
alors on pourra parler d'autorité
légitime et ainsi obtenir l'adhésion par
respect et non par soumission en
infantilisant ou en manipulant le
sentiment de
peur perdre l'école ce n'est pas perdre
une bataille ni offrir une prise de
guerre à l'adversaire c'est perdre la
guerre il convient maintenant de se
pencher sur ce qui a été mis en place du
côté du ministère de l'Intérieur il y a
tout d'abord Faros cette plateforme
censé effectuer une veille sur les
réseaux sociaux en s'appuyant notamment
sur des signalements émis par les
citoyens quelques mois après l'attentat
qui a coûté sa vie à mon frère dans
l'émission La Fabrique du mensonge j'ai
pu voir Monsieur Laurent Nunez àur cor
ordinateur national du renseignement de
la lutte contre le terrorisme se
féliciter d'avoir triplé les effectifs
de Faros soit un peu plus de 90
policiers et gendarmes cela pourrait
passer pour une bonne nouvelle si les
signalements entre 2020 et 2021
n'avaient pas triplé également ce qui
revient donc mathématiquement au même il
convient aussi de s'interroger sur les
capacités et modalités d'analyse des
données et sur le traitement qui en
découle que dire également des réseaux
sociaux qui semble être devenu le lieu
privilégié de la calomnie toutes les
propagandes le travail de modérateur de
ces médias semble fortement limité sans
même que nous en comprenions
véritablement les critères je vous
signale également qu'il a fallu plus de
3 mois pour que je parvienne par le
biais de mon avocate à faire supprimer
la vidéo de Monsieur schnina mis en
examen pour assistance d'un projet
terroriste contre mon frère par facebook
France étrangement Faros qui pourtant
cette fois avait reçu de nombreux
signalements n'a pas uvré ou n'a pas pu
la faire
supprimer je verse maintenant à mon
témoignage quatre articles de presse
écrites prier
article article de Libération du 17
octobre 2020 intitulé Conflant une note
de renseignement retrace la chronologie
des jours précédents l'attentat article
de Mariane 28 octobre 2020 intitulé dans
les ivblines la grande compromission
d'élu avec l'islam radical article du
Parisien du 30 octobre 2020 intitulé
après l'attentat de Conflant le Conseil
des instances musulmanes des ivelines
dans la tourmente article de la Gazette
en Eveline du 13 novembre 2020 intitulé
mis en cause le répond à ses
détracteurs je me livrerai à une
extraction d'éléments factuels de ces
articles les renseignements territoriaux
des ivelines dépend de la Direction
centrale du renseignement intérieur
autrement appelé
rt78 ils ont rédigé une note daté du 12
octobre 2020 soulignant que je cite la
communication a visiblement permis
d'apaiser les tensions et que pour
l'heure les responsables de la
communauté musulmane local ne se sont
pas manifesté alors que visiblement de
son propre aveu lu Simi conseil des
institutions musulmanes des ivlines
avait eu connaissance de l'affaire des
caricatures que je
cite des démarches amiables avait eu
lieu et que la situation s'était apaisée
et cela avant le 16 octobre le SIMI
s'attribue un rôle de médiateur entre la
communauté musulmane et l'État monsieur
Abdelaziz El jaorri ancien secrétaire du
Simi déplore que je cite nos instances
ont failli avant l'attentat car n'ont
pas permis d'éteindre la polémique et
d'intervenir auprès de ce père de
famille il mentionnera également avoir
reçu la vidéo du père donc monsieur
schnina le 12 octobre 2020 par un des
membres du Simi le SIMI ne désavouera
pas qu'il y ait eu partage de vidéo mais
parlera je cite d'une pure erreur
matérielle en condamnant cet acte à
postériori le SIMI a conclu avoir rempli
sa part du contrat comme il le dit en
effectuant des démarches amiables et en
constatant que la situation était
apaisée quelle était donc la nature du
contrat quels ont été les critères
objectifs pour dire que la situation
était apaisée de mots apaisés et cette
analyse fallacieuse se retrouveront
ensuite tel quel dans la note des rt78
du 12 octobre 2020 et dans le rapport du
référent à laïcité daté du 12 octobre
2020 que vous pourouvez retrouver dans
le rapport de
l'IGR maintenant il me semble important
de revenir sur le terme de
médiateur je me pose effectivement des
questions sur l'impartialité d'une
organisation musulmane pour mener une
négociation entre deux parties adverses
ce qui sous-entend également la
légitimité des revendications religieuse
d'un côté et républicaine de l'autre les
parties prenantes doivent alors
effectuer des compromis pour trouver un
accord est-ce bien le rôle de l'État ou
de ses représentants étant donné leur
neutralité de composer avec des
revendications
islamistes je vais tenter de vous
montrer la fausseté de l'ensemble et
comment un groupe confessionnel a réussi
ce coup de maîre en dupant
l'état si on se base sur le nique note d
RT il semblerait que le seul paramètre
d'évaluation de la situation soit que
les responsables de la communauté
musulmane locale se manifestent avec une
probable médiatisation je cite menace de
sitine ou de manifestation pour rappel
ce risque de médiatisation est également
important pour l'éducation nationale les
menaces de trouble à l' publicique sont
devenus le cheval de tro d'intégristes
musulmans prétendument offensés chaque
offense se traduira par des
manifestations bruillantes voire
violentes c'est ainsi que l'on vide le
délit de blasphème de tout caractère
religieux le blasphème trouve ainsi sa
traduction séculière et perpertue sa
condamnation la préservation de l'ordre
public fait partie des prérogatives d'un
état de droit alors au nom de la
préservation de l'ordre public on finit
par prenner le concept de préservation
de la paix religieuse en demandant avis
conseil et action aux représentants de
la communauté musulmane on réhabilite
inévitablement le délit de blasphème et
la condamnation par d'quipéation qui va
avec la neutralité de l'État en France
aurait dû pourtant nous en prémunir
je reviens maintenant sur les propos
tenus par Monsieur Darmanin le 7 avril
2022 sur BFM TV il a souhaité faire écho
à notre dépôt de plainte contre son
ministère il a précisé que nul ne
pouvait prévoir le passage à lac d'zarov
habitant à plus de 80 km qualifiant
ainsi de fatalité l'événement ajoutant
que son ministère n'aurait pas en rugir
il précisera également je cite l'État
n'a rien à cacher l'État était au
rendez-vous il l'a protégé et il
continue de protéger
je viens rappeler que les forces de
police sont soumises à l'obligation de
moyen obligation en vertu de laquelle
les forces de l'ordre doivent déployer
tous les efforts pour atteindre
l'objectif visé visiblement il y a eu
défaut de moyen à moins que l'objectif
visé n''est pas eu été de sauver mon
frère afin de mieux comprendre ce que je
vous avance permettez-moi de vous lire
maintenant quelques extraits du
livre notre solitude de Yannick hnel
chronique cœur au journal Charlie Hebdo
depuis 2015 il a ouvert le procès de
janvier 2015 durant 2 mois et
demi je vous invite bien évidemment à le
lire ce livre moi qui ai pu me sentir
tantôt lui tantôt dans son désarroi
d'être narrateur ce que jeux ce que je
fais aujourd'hui tantôt les victimes de
l'attentat de
Charlie excusez-moi qui sont victimes
sans accepter d'en être ce que je suis
aussi il y aura toujours un lien qui ne
sera pas à la limite de la raison mais
au-delà c'est ce qui me permet non sans
une certaine révolte de prendre la
hauteur nécessaire pour comprendre et
que dans nuit sans sommeil on se
retrouve dans notre solitude en d'autres
circonstances je vous aurai lu d'autres
extraits je vous lis les pages 132 à
134 le téléphone sonna j'ai décroché
c'était Julien il m'a dit qu'il avait
une bonne nouvelle et une mauvaise
nouvelle la mauvaise c'est que depuis la
replication des caricatures suite aux
menaces qui ne cessaient de s'amplifier
le niveau de tension était monté si haut
que le ministère de l'Intérieur avait
décidé de nous donner à Bou et à moi une
protection je ne comprenais pas quelle
protection Julien précisa une protection
policière vous aurez chacun un officier
de sécurité il n'avait pas de menace
précise à l'encontre de Bou et moi me
dit-il le risque n'était que diffus mais
la tension internationale était à son
comble le président Erdogan et son
gouvernement déchînit le monde musulman
contre la France et comme le président
Macron lui avait résisté en défendant la
laïcité à la française nous étions
entrés dans une période d'affrontement
sur les réseaux les appel au meurtrre se
multipliait Charlie Hebdo était en
première ligne et le fait que se tienne
en ce moment un procès contre le
terrorisme islamiste exacerber les
passions négatives fin d'après-midi le
24 septembre je suis allé place bovau le
commissaire françois b m'a reçu pour me
faire signer une lettre officielle de
prise en charge par la
SDLP si je résume les deux chroniquurs
qui ont retracé le procès de l'attentat
de Charlie Hebdo ont bénéficié d'une
mise sous protection par les services de
la SDLP le 24 septembre 2020 alors que
comme le soulligne Hel il n'avait pas de
menaces précises à son
encontre je précise également que le 25
septembre 2020 un projet d'attentat
avorté contre Charlie a eu lieu à leur
ancienne adresse blessant néanmoins deux
personnes de l'agence de presse première
ligne avec une feuille de bouché cela
invitera à récidive comme le prouvera le
mois d'octobre sanglant qui a suivi et
en cela je pense également à Vincent
Simone et Nadine assassinés dans la
basilique de Nice le 29
octobre si je résume le contexte
était-il différent les jours précédents
le 16 octobre jour de la mise à mort de
mon frère la réponse est non Samuel
avait-il reçu des menates précises à son
encontre par des individus proches de la
mouvance islamiste la réponse est oui
est-ce qu'il y avait rupture d'anonymat
la réponse est encore oui était-il
question de caricature de Charlie Hebdo
la réponse est encore et encore oui
alors qu'avait-il de moins ou
qu'avait-il de plus une personne anonyme
n'encourtt-elle pas les mêmes risques
qu'un sujet connu une personne anonyme
n-elle pas traité avec autant d'égard
qu'un sujet connu s'il y a une
différence de traitement entre les
individus que devient la notion
d'égalité
je vous propose maintenant de vous
pencher sur les propos tenus par
monsieur Éric Dupont Moretti actuel
ministre de la Justice dans les myticle
du Sénat le 2 avril
2021 c'est toujours difficile de
réécrire l'histoire mais nous nous
sommes dit qu'est-ce qui aurait Perm
permis d'éviter ça si je vous dis rien
c'est désespérant mais c'est la réalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
conçu l'article
18 l'article 18 ou plutôt l'article
223-1-1 du code pénal sanctionne le fait
de révéler des informations relatives à
une personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique ou chargé d'une mission de
service public les peines encourues sont
de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et 75000 €
d'amende je m'interroge bien bien
évidemment sur les informations détenues
par Monsieur Dupont Marti à cette même
date pour tenir de tels propos faut-il
rappeler qu'un témoignage ne fait pas
enquête M que rien n'aurait pu l'éviter
c'est déjà un grand exercice de
réctiture des faits monsieur le ministre
lui-même ancien avocat au barreau de
Paris ne peut nier l'existence d'un
puissant arsenal juridique qui aurait pu
protéger mon frère s'il avait été
appliqué le tout n'est pas d'étoffer le
code pénal même s'il est effectivement
perfectible mais c'est de restaurer la
force de la loi en l'appliquant pour
lutter contre la loi de la force il leur
manquait sans doute le consensus
politique pour que les service de
sécurité intérieure soit autorisé à
intervenir consensus qui ne semble
exister que lorsque l'État état
d'urgence est déclaré soit après chaque
attentat et non
avant j'enais donc monsieur le Président
Macron a honoré ses propos tenus à brut
le 8 avril 2022 je cite on va tout
mettre à plat et regarder et Monsieur
damarnin à BFM le 7 avril 2022 je cite
il faudra que l'État dise tout ce qu'il
a pu faire c'est normal dans un état de
droit et bien
j'attends pour finir car je ne peux
conclure tant il y aurait encore à dire
oui j'en veux bien évidemment à ceux qui
croyaient accomplir un travail alors
qu'ils avaient un métier laissant de
côté leur savoir-faire préfant un savoir
se taire et au besoin un savoir faire
taire la dessence lu été de le
reconnaître et de faire Amand honorable
c'est la base du savoir être dans ce
monde on est plus on aucié le paraître à
l'être oui j'en veux également à ceux
qui choisissent une vérité alternative
défendue par quelques courtisans
cherchant carrière cette vérité erronée
et rassurante pour eux et les maintient
dans l'entre soi on néprouve jamais de
la honte face à soi-même lorsque
certains craignent le regard des autres
le jugement c'est bien que celui-ci les
renvoie à leur propre culpabilité dans
ce monde on détourne le regard de
l'autre ou bien on ferme carrément les
yeux oui j'en veux à ces éternels
adeptes de l'idéologie du P vaguisme
ceux qui sont les premiers à se mettre à
genoux et à regarder tomber ceux qui
sont restés debout ce murmura à
l'oreille ah tu vois on a bien fait de
se coucher dans cette partie géante de
un de TR soleil le maître mot est ta
bougé tu dégages cette pathologie
paralysante et tétanisante semble avoir
atteint par contagion l'état tout entier
la culture de pvag sur l'alibiie à la
soumission terme injurieux mais surtout
inavoable pour être capable et coupable
du pire il faut bien se trouver des
raisons dans ce monde on valorise le
sujet obéissant passif parfois lâche et
on dénigre en qualifiant de traître le
sujet rebelle qui pourtant a agit comme
il convient au sens de la morale au sein
d'une société fortement hiérarchisée
agir comme il convient c'est d'abord au
contraire faire ce que l'autorité exige
de sorte que quiconque s'oppose à elle
s'expose à la réprobation générale loin
d'être considéré comme un héros que
pourtant Monsieur le Président Macron a
pu le dire le 21 octobre 2020 lors de
l'hommage national tenu à la Sorbonne le
sujet résistant est traité comme un
paria tenu à l'isolement et livré à la
vindicte populaire ce qui conduira mon
frère a être livré seul en pature à la
mouvance islamiste mon frère a été
reconnu par certains et à tort coupable
de déloyauté le coût de sa désobéissance
sera qu'il finira seul et que l'État
n'nera pas sa part du contrat social en
lui assurant
protection le dernier condamné à mort
pour blasphème en France n'est plus
François Jean le FF de la barre exécuté
en 1766 à abeville c'est désormais
Samuel Patti exécuté en 2020 à Conflant
saint-honorine combien combien de temps
vous faudra-t-il pour comprendre que la
culture de la Libye soit religieuse soit
ethnique est utilisée pour commettre les
pires exactions finalement à vouloir
éviter discrimination et stigmatisation
cette attitude amalgame et réduit au
silence ceux qui pensent comme mon frère
que je cite la vie de l'homme est le
droit le plus sacré qu'-ils appris après
ça si je vous dis rien c'est désespérant
mais c'est la réalité estce qu' a que
l'horreur de ce vendredi 13 octobre qui
va me donner raison merci de votre
attention merci Madame nous allons
maintenant recueillir les interventions
de ceux qui le souhaitent sont déjà
inscrits Monsieur Henri Leroi et
Monsieur Jacques groserin si d'autres
collègues le souhaitent vous signalez on
vous notera bien évidemment Monsieur L
rooi pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Madame
Patti nous avons été particulièrement
attentifs à votre pourriez adresser
concomitamment au président du Sénat et
au président de la commission des lois
qui a entraîné la création cette
commission d'information avec les
pouvoirs d'une commission d'enquête
devant laquelle vous venez de témoigner
avec une émouvante dignité soyez-en
remercier quelques précisions me
paraissent uti à savoir puisque je n'ai
que 2 minutes votre famille a-t-elle été
informé associé au consulté dans les
discussions concernant la sécurité de
Samuel après qu'il ait été
menacé votre dramatique expérience vous
permet-t-elle aujourd'hui de suggérer
des mesures et je sais que c'est le
combat de votre vie et je le comprends
et je l'approuve de suggérer des mesures
préventives qui vous paraissent
indispensable à la protection et à
l'accompagnement des enseignants qui
viendrai à vivre une situation telle que
votre frère l'a subi avant son
assassinat je vous remercie merci
monsieur monsieur le sénateur Monsieur
Jacques groperin puis Madame Jacqueline
sagebgot merci monsieur le Président il
est difficile de réagir en tout cas de
vous questionner après vos propos tant
ils sont poignants courageux et ils
incitent le
respect vous avez dit et on vous
remercie en tout cas de du courage et
votre présence qu'il y avait une
faillite administrative politique que la
méthode était mauvaise vous nous avez
parlé de politiquement correct qu'il
fallait justement dépassé et beaucoup
d'empathie moi je voudrais vous demander
qu'est-ce qui vous met le plus en colère
3 ans après l'assassinat de de votre
frère vous l'avez exprimé à travers les
médias dans la presse suite à
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard qui
s'est passé pour votre frère à
l'extérieur de l'établissement scolaire
pour Dom Bernard à l'intérieur peut-être
un jour et on le souhaite pas dans la
classe on s'interroge par rapport à cela
en tout cas nous en avons crainte et
enfin il est légitime de vous demander
ce que vous pensez sur ce qui est ce qui
a été décidé et annoncé depuis
l'assassinat de votre frère pour éviter
qu'un tel acte se reproduisent merci
Monsieur grosérin Madame jacine sage
brigot puis madame Marie- piierre
Monier merci monsieur le Président tout
d'abord Michel je voulais vous remercier
d'avoir dit tout ce que vous avez dit
parce qu'il faut savoir dire et savoir
dénoncer l'horreur avec les bons mots
parce qu'on a tendance depuis longtemps
dans ce pays à ne pas employer les bons
mots et vous les avez employés et pour
ça je voulais vous en dire un grand
merci je connais votre souffrance je
connais la souffrance de votre famille
et je sais que de témoigner aujourd'hui
devant nous tous c'était une manière
pour vous de dire mon frère a donné sa
vie parce que la République ne l'a pas
défendu ça je le sais aussi donc merci
je pense que nous sommes pas
suffisamment nombreux pour dénoncer ce
qui met en péril notre démocratie notre
liberté et à travers
l'assassinat de votre frère c'est ça qui
est posé aujourd'hui aussi alors je
voudrais vraiment vous remercier pour
les mots extrêmement forts que vous avez
prononcé aujourd'hui et vous avez mon
admiration pour cela je voulais vous le
dire après vous avez un engagement
aujourd'hui pour protéger l'école ça je
le sais hier soir vous l'avez fait
admirablement à Paris dans un théâtre
pensez-vous qu'aujourd'hui les
enseignants qui arrivent dans les écoles
qui sont formés dans les lieux
spécifiques aujourd'hui soit très
conscient des menaces qui pèsent sur
l'école d'aujourd'hui et de demain
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on les arme
suffisamment pour défendre cette laïcité
cette école de la République qui a qui
devrait permettre à chaque enfant de se
construire dans la liberté avec la
possibilité de dire et ne pas dire des
choses de critiquer des choses sans être
menacé moi je pense qu'il y a un vrai
sujet et je voudrais avoir votre analyse
sur cette école d'aujourd'hui avec des
enseignants qui se sensurent avec des
enseignants qui refuseraient de
travailler aujourd'hui dans une école où
un collège qui s'appellerait Samuel pati
est-ce que cela vous inquiète et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez effectivement
de l'école d'aujourd'hui face à à cette
vague d'offensise islamique dans nos
écoles merci Madame sage brigot madame
Marie piierre Monier ensuite madame pati
je vous donnerai la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Madame je voudrais saluer votre courage
et votre abnégation dans le combat qui
est le vôre depuis 3 ans dans un
contexte qui menace de basculer vers une
forme d'impuissance face à l'ampleur de
la tâche des voix comme la vôtre tel des
électrochocs sont des électrochocs qu'il
faut entendre nous devons le redire avec
clarté l'obscurantisme s'attaque à la
seule institution capable de former des
adultes qui aimeront la différence le
dialogue la complexité qui chercheront
intérêt général comment lutter contre
cet obscurantisme qui a pour mission de
qui doit accompagner celles et ceux qui
vont instruire nos enfants pour qu'ils
deviennent des citoyenes des citoyens
éclairés comment redonner corps à la
devise républicaine liberté égalité
fraternité pour qu'elle soit une réalité
pour tout le monde ce sont d'immenses
défim et préoccupations qu'il nous faut
largement au-delà des cvages partisans
arrivver à relever j'auraai quelques
questions savoir quel est-ce que vous
avez toujours un contact avec la
communauté enseignante que ce soit celle
qui était autour de votre frère ou
d'autres est-ce que vous ils font pe
appel à
vous au-delà de l'approche sécuritaire
quelle réponse faut-il selon vous
apporter aujourd'hui à l'école
républicaine et à ses enfants
meurtris et au cœur de l'attentat qui a
frappé Samuel pati votre frère il y a la
question de la laïcité qui se pose et
vous en avez bien parlé est-ce que là
vous avez un retour de la part des
enseignants comment se sentent-il armé
outillé pour la transmettre d'un point
de vue pédagogique et pour faire face
aux incompréhensions qui entourent cette
notion dans l'espace public est-ce que
vous avez des pistes à
préconiser merci Madame Monier alors
madame paatti vous avez la parole pour
les questions qui vous ont été adressées
ça été un peu rapide pour moi besoin je
vous
rolliciterai donc euh pour répondre donc
sénateur le roi donc par rapport à si
effectivement notre famille n'a jamais
été informé à de de menaces que mon
frère pouvait avoir à cette époque-là je
ne vous le cacherai pas que Samuel
lui-même nous en avait pas informé
d'autant que mon père avait été quand
même très malade à ce moment-là et que
on n pas spécialement des personnes à
vouloir inquiéter nos
proches parce que effectivement lui il
pensait qu'il qu'il était plus ou moins
protégé que même s'il était très très
inquiet et que il l'avait écrit dans un
de ses mails auquels il avait
correspondu donc avec la principale en
expliquant qu'il qu'il croyait en la
justice et que du coup il pensait qu'en
tout cas euh à la fin il allait gagner
grâce à la justice sauf que
malencontreusement ben il est mort avant
qu'il ait pu y avoir justice par rapport
au propos calomieux que monsieur schnina
a pu faire envers mon frère ou monsieur
sifreoui il y avait une autre question
monsieur Leroi je me rappelle
plus expérience qu'est-ce que vous
conseillerez à ceux qui
pourraient être dans cette situation aux
enseignants qui pourrait et on l'a vu
dernièrement encore se retrouver dans ce
type de situation
ave dramatique expérience mais écoutez
malheureusement je pense qu'à l'heure
actuelle la première attitude qu'il faut
parce que vous voyez bien que le risque
est avéré et c'est encore avéré ce
vendredi c'est effectivement que
l'enseignant et que l'institution lui
propose d'embler une mise en retrait
c'est ça se fait de suite il y a pas
besoin de remplir des formulaires
extraordinaires et d'ailleurs donc ça a
été fait pour d'autres professeurs qui à
mes yeux n'avaient pas les mêmes risques
ou n'encourrait pas les mêmes risques
donc je pense que c'est le premier geste
de l'éducation nationale à faire et
après à évaluer effectivement si mise
sous protection par la SDLP qui doit
être faite par les services de
l'Intérieur ensuite qu'est-ce qui a été
fait depuis alors j'ai beaucoup suivi
hein ce qui a été fait depuis surtout
pour l'éducation
nationale bah ce que j'en ai vu c'est
qu'il y a eu des des circulaires qui ont
été sortis d'ailleurs je vous en ai mis
quelques pièces dans le dossier qui sera
versé au dossier c'est que la dernière
circulaire qui était paru eff
effectivement en fa elle est très bien
faite mais en fin de compte elle ne elle
n'apporte rien de plus elle permet
effectivement un système réflexe de
procédure à effectuer si a menace tout
de suite prévenir la police tout de
suite faire remonter au rectorat et
cetera mais en fait tout ça ça existait
avant ils ont fait juste une fiche
rflexe qui permet en fin de compte une
facilité d'utilisation mais à mes yeux
je n'ai pas vu
de d'amélioration et plutôt même parfois
des procédures qui sont très compliquées
où il faut effectivement remplir
plusieurs exemplaires prévenir plusieurs
personnes et en fait le côté fastidieux
parfois empêche qu'il y ait une réaction
efficace parce que quand il y a des
menaces bah on attend pas que ça passe
et que ça redescende et que ça mette 4
jours il faut parfois être réactif
presque à la minute c'est ce que je
déploore un feu c'est qu'en fin de
compte on rajoute on rajoute alors que
parfois il faudrait un petit peu
clarifier pour
réussir
donc Madame
brigot me posiez la question donc pour
les jeunes professeurs qui arrivent sur
le terrain
Z moi je pense que les jeunes quand même
il ils ont conscience de de la
difficulté donc certains sont très très
motivés ils ont envie de porter tout ça
mais beaucoup sont quand même dans une
culture de la laïcité dite ouverte à
l'anglo-saxone
ce qui fait qu'en fin de compte ils ne
comprennent pas qu'en fin de compte nous
en France on a lacité on a la loi de
1905 pardon la loi de 2004 qui interdit
le le port de signe religieux et euh et
du coup à la fin on se retrouve
effectivement avec les gentils profs
jeunes et les anciens profs qui le sont
plus tout autant donc l'école
d'aujourd'hui oui il y a un peu une
fracture entre les jeunes enseignants et
les plus
anciens par rapport au nom du du collège
de mon frère il nous a été dit
effectivement peu dans les jours qui ont
suivi sa mort que son collège où il
avait exercé à porté son
nom donc tout le monde était bien sûr
très content de nous l'annoncer euh
néanmoins de ce qui s'est passé dans la
réalité c'est que rapidement on a vu que
des personnes s'y opposaient notamment
donc le personnel sur place qui était un
peu dans la crainte et cetera donc bon
de toute façon on a laissé faire les
procédures on va pas forcer les gens à
faire ça même si effectivement la
symbolique était bien sûr importante et
on manque je pense un petit peu
cruellement de symbole et de figure de
prou en France
mais donc là nous donc nous sommes au 3
ans de ce que j'en sais pour l'année
prochaine parce qu'ils attendaient sous
un prétexte que tous les élèves qui
avaient pu connaître mon frère et
quitter l'établissement donc ce qui sera
le cas en fin d'année scolaire 2023-
2024 néanmoins de ce que j'en ai vu par
voie de presse le maire de conflan
saint-honorine est en train de trouver
un squir qui n'est même pas construit
pour donner ce nom à ce squir au nom de
mon frère comme ça la prochaine fois on
dira bah il y a déjà un squir on ne peut
pas donner le nom du collège voilà c'est
voilà ce que j'en
pense donc après un peu plus loin euh
donc pour les contacts par rapport à la
communité enseignante donc tout d'abord
la communité enseignante de conflan
saint-honerine où j'ai été en attache
j'essaie à peu près de vous résumer
pendant à peu près un an et demi où euh
une partie de ma famille nous nous
sommes même rendus une fois au sein de
l'établissement scolaire pour les 1 an
où ils avaient effectivement organisé
euh tout un travail avec les élèves dans
une séquence un peu émotion voilà
euh il eu un petit peu un une fracture
de ma part à un certain moment parce que
par rapport à l'enquête donc côté pénal
euh donc le l'inspecteur en charge de
l'enquête donc m'a sollicité ben
donnez-moi trois nom de personnes
professeur sur place pour aller déposer
et quand ils m'ont répondu qu'ils ne
voulit pas y aller j'ai je vous avoue
que je l'ai vécu comme ce qu'a vécu mon
frère avec le lâcha de ses collègues
donc je leur ai spécifié que je les a en
informé que de toute façon s'il recevait
une convocation de police ils étaient
obligé de s'y rendre mais je ne
m'attendais pas à cette réponse des
personnes qui pourtant avaient eu des
discours pendant ces un an et demi qui
qui était bien je vous avoue que voilà
j'ai j'ai senti ce qu' avit vécu mon
frère là je l'ai senti vraiment cette
grande
solitude donc après pour d'autres
enseignants alors ça j'en ai rencontré
beaucoup après il y a des côtés assez
formidables parce que les endroits où
j'étis invité à intervenir sur la
journée de la licité sur les fake news
parce qu'on m'a invité sur plein de
sujets du coup j'ai beaucoup travaillé
mais ben j'ai rencontré des gens
formidables et qui me réinvite ben il me
tu toi vous imaginez bien tu reviendras
l'année prochaine on fera plein de
choses voilà et eux ça leur fait
beaucoup de bien parce qu'ils se sentent
seuls nos profs terriblement seul et et
le fait qu'en fin de compte que je sois
là pour aller soutenir pour aller mener
un cours difficile auprès d'élèves qui
vont être forcément et ben ça donne un
tout autre sens
voilà après pour les pistes sur la
laïcité je pense qu'effectivement on en
peut-être un peu trop à nos profs je
pense que tout ce qui est sujet un petit
peu difficile justement ça rejoint un
petit peu le fait quand je suis
intervenu je pense qu'effectivement il y
a des travaux qui se mènent peut-être à
deux qui effectivement des intervenants
extérieur qui puisse venir en renfort
des professeurs qui sont sur place et
pourtant c'est une idée il me semble qui
date de 2015 qui s'appelle la réserve
citoyenne il me semble je suis pas
professeur mais j'ai travaillé la
réserve citoyenne où cette idée avait
été sortie qui pourtant je pense cétait
une piste intéressante à utiliser donc
des acteurs de la vie civile pour
intervenir sur plein de choses moi je
vous raconte une anecdote tout à fait
autre je travaille avec des sages-femmes
qui elles-mêmes voudraient intervenir
pour parler d'éducation de contraception
et elles ne peuvent pas alors que
pourtant elles auraient toute leur place
à agir en milieu
scolaire madame on va continuer il y a
encore quelques questions en commençant
par Husain
Bourgi merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame je voulais commencer
par saluer la mémoire de votre frère qui
éit un homme qui avait choisi son métier
qui était un homme épanoui un enseignant
heureux qui aimait ce qu'il faisait et
qui aimait ses
élèves je voulais vous dire ensuite que
j'ai été profondément marqué par les
propos que vous avez tenu tout à l'heure
des propos particulièrement graves des
propos particulièrement forts qui ont
raisonné chez moi et je crois comme
beaucoup de collègues et celles et ceux
qui nous regardent comme un réquisitoire
un réquisitoire complètement justifié
contre une institution qui me fait
davantage penser par moment à la grande
muette enfermé dans un splendide
corporatisme et qui ne sait pas être à
la hauteur lorsqu'un de ses agent ou un
de ses élèves est en situation de danger
je voulais madame vous remercier de ce
témoignage et de dialoguer avec nous
aujourd'hui en vous posant deux
questions avez-vous le sentiment
aujourd'hui que la mort de votre frère a
servi à quelque chose et la deuxième
question que je voulais vous poser tout
à l'heure mes collègues vous ont
interrogé sur la mesure princip qui
pourrait être mise en œuvre pour venir
en appui à un enseignant une enseignante
confrontter à cette situation moi je
voulais vous demander est-ce que vous
avez une idée de la mesure que
l'éducation nationale pourrait mettre en
place pour accompagner un élève ou un
parent d'élèv qui serait justement
opposé à un enseignant pouvant proférer
des menaces et allant jusqu'à attenter à
sa vie une chose est de d'assurer la
protection de l'enseignant une chose
étant de retirer l'enseignant mais le
problème reste entier qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire à l'égard de ces enfants
et de leur famille et je vais conclure
chè madame en vous disant qu'à
Montpellier nous avons une école Samuel
pti qui a été inaugurée en septembre
2022 qui fait notre fierté et c'est un
honneur pour nous que d'avoir une école
qui porte le nom de votre frère dans ma
ville Max
Brisson je suis professeur d'histoire et
donc j'ai été partiement sensible madame
à votre témoignage parce que lorsqu'on
assassine un professeur d'histoire c'est
quelque chose de parement difficile pour
la République et je veux dire aussi la
difficulté qui est la mienne comme ça
exprimé par d'autres à dire trouver des
mots après votre message enpr de colère
et de dignité je voudrais vous
interroger sur deux points d'abord vous
avez dit que dans la période qui a
précédé l'assassinat de votre frère
l'institution ni la menace islamique et
voulait et pointer un un problème
d'ordre
pédagogique cela renvoie en effet à
terrible pas de vague que nous dénonçons
et que l'institution continue fortement
de nier le deuxème point que je voudrais
évoquer c'est la il a été par Jacqueline
stagebgot je voudrais revenir c'est la
formation des professeurs à la laïcité
tel que notre République la porte et à
partir de laquelle notre République
s'est fondée malheureusement et bien des
rapports le montrent dans les inspect
c'est souvent une autre forme de laïcité
plus
anglosaxon qui est enseignée une laïcité
relative une laïcité
ouverte notre République à travers son
école ne s'est pas construite au travers
d'une
relative ou deun laïcité
ouverte est-ce que ce qui se passe ce
qui s'est passé il y a 3
ans lors de l'assassinat de votre frre
ce qui se passe par tous les actes de
remise en cause de la laïcité dans les
écoles de République n'est pas le signe
de la faillite par
l'Université de la formation des
professeurs et n'est-il pas temps au
moment où le ministre parle d'école
normale du 21e siècle de que l'éducation
nationale reprenne en main la formation
des professeurs pour reprendre leur
redonner les réarmer intellectuellement
en matière d'enseignement des principes
de notre République et du principe de
laïcité je vous remercie colombe
brossell merci monsieur le Président
c'est évidemment le cœur lourd qu'on
vous écoute et qu'on se permet de de
vous interroger madame
Py des professeurs d'histoire et de
géographie à lancé en 2021 un prix et je
crois que vous participez aux travaux de
du comité de de pilotage
qui récompense si je peux le dire ainsi
des travaux de collégiens et de leurs
enseignants avec l'idée de travailler
sur des travaux collectifs et sur sur la
base notamment de de
l'EMC j'avais envie envie de de vous
demander quel est votre regard sur ces
différents prix mais au-delà des prix
finalement sur l'utilité du travail qui
a été porté par ces enseignants et ses
collégiens qui sont venus jusqu'à
proposer au comité de pilotage des
projets quelle est votre perception 2
ans c'est évidemment trop court pour
évaluer ce que ça a produit mais quelle
est votre perception à vous de là où
vous êtes sur l'utilité la nécessité de
de ces
travaux pierre
ouyas merci Monsieur le le Président
Madame je dois vous avouer mon mon
émotion et et ma honte aussi à votre à
votre discours que j'ai trouvé d'une
d'une force extraordinaire d'une dignité
et d' et d'une exigence qui qui s'impose
qui qui s'impose à nous pour trouver des
solutions euh vous parlez de de votre
frère avec
beaucoup de beaucoup d'humilité et vous
nous dites et je trouve que la
comparaison est est très forte que c'est
l'équivalent du du chevalier de La Barre
et et je vous suis sur cette comparaison
c'est un un martyre de la laïcité un
martyre de de la laïcité républicaine
quand quand je vous entends parler de
votre frère je je pense à cette phrase
de de Ferdinan buisson qui disait que
l'école de la République elle doit
former des républicains et et c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui ce qui nous manque
le plus c'est-à-dire une une morale
républicaine républicaine qui distingue
entre entre tous et et tout ce qui'est
l'école de de la
République
sur les solutions qu'on pourrait
apporter ça fait plusieurs mois que
j'essaie de porter une idée mais
malheureusement je vais pas rentrer dans
le détail mais c'est pas un sénateur qui
peut le faire c'est l'idée d'accorder
deux droits à chaque enseignant la
protection fonctionnelle c'estàdire
qu'elle soit pas décidée par le chef
d'établissement par un supérieur mais
qu'elle lui soit octroyée de droit
quitte ensuite à la retirer si les faits
sont considérés comme d'une moindre
importance mais je crois que ça serait
pour les enseignant d'abord une preuve
de confiance et ensuite un élément qui
leur permettrait justement de de prendre
courage et et d'aller plus loin euh je
partage totalement votre sentiment sur
euh les les périls qui menacent la
laïcité euh plusieurs collègues l'ont
dit euh nous sommes menacé de
l'intérieur par par l'idéologie
islamiste qui s'attaque à ce qui fait le
le cœur de notre républque c'est-à-dire
l'esprit critique et la raison euh mais
aussi par les institutions européennes
VO qui sont en train de de promouvoir
euh une une forme de laïcité qui est la
la pardon la neutralité religieuse mais
la neutralité religieuse ce n'est pas la
laïité et je crois que il serait temps
aujourd'hui que dans un grand mouvement
national nous puissions débattre de
façon souveraine de tout ça et je me
demandais si la constitutionnalisation
de la loi de 1905 pourrait pas porter ce
message politique très fort c'est-à-dire
la réappropriation par toute la nation
de ce qu'est la laïcité à à la française
je vous remercie
madame alors est-ce que la mort de mon
frère a servit à quelque chose bon comme
vous le savez si ça vait servver à
quelque chose peut-être que Monsieur
Dominique Bernard ser sera encore là
donc je je pense
qu'effectivement les mesures n'ont pas
du tout été prises puisque l'affaire de
mon frère n absolument pas été analysé
parce qu'il faut quand même comprendre
que ce qui arrivve à mon frère on peut
effectivement pointer des
responsabilités à droite à gauche mais
c'est surtout comprendre l'entrisme
islamique qui est à l'actuel dans nos
écoles et qui prend de plus en plus de
place et
que si c'est pas entre guillemets une
menace de décapitation ça on va passer à
la menace d'une bombe la société est
devenue un chaos en fait à l'heure
actuelle donc autrement
donc donc par rapport donc aux
revendications donc des élèves ou des
parents d'élèves qui peuvent être
menassant
donc effectivement ce qu'il faut surtout
donc ça retourne sur l'islamisme il faut
faut mener un combat
idéologique parce que en fin de compte
les mesures correctives on va protéger
un professeur et vincer un élève le
mettre dans un établissement on va faire
convoquer le père de famille qui a pu
menacer et qui sera jugé souvent sous
des peines qui sont tout à fait
négligeables donc en fin de compte ça
entraîne récidive parce qu'en fait on
déplace les problème c'est un petit peu
comme si on appuyait sur un cancer et
qu'on disème des cellules cancéreuses un
petit peu partout
donc voilà par par rapport à ça pour moi
c'est c'est vraiment un combat que tout
le monde doit mener contre l'islamisme à
l'heure actuelle
qui effectivement est en pleine
offensive et qui va de plus en plus
vite donc par rapport à la formation des
professeurs en
insp donc pour avoir côtoyé quelques
formateurs en insp qui eux-mêmes
effectivement sont déjà fourvoyés dans
une laïcité ouverte transmettent
forcément une laïcité ouverte donc
effectivement au niveau des universités
puis on en parle quand même assez
régulièrement on voit bien que ces
enfants donc enfin ces jeunes
adultes sont un petit peu effectivement
écartés c'est vrai que je ne comprendrai
jamais pourquoi on a un ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et un ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur parce que je
pense que quand même il y a une certaine
continuité entre les deux et de les
avoir dissociés en fin de compte il y a
un traitement qui est totalement
différent dans l'enseignement supérieur
où la règle de 2000 la loi de 2004 n'est
pas appliquée donc une certaine
incohérence je pense dans le
fonctionnement d'avoir séparé les deux
ministères ou qu'il ait pas entre
guillemets une relation beaucoup plus
étroite entre les deux et une
certaine voilà que ça soit cohérent dans
son ensemble en fait il y une histoire
sur le pas de vague par contte j'ai un
peu
effacé c'est ouais oui
c'était pardon c'était ce que vous avez
dit dans votre intervention préliminaire
sur la période qui a précédé
l'assassinat de votre frère et vous avez
indiqué qu'il y avait une négation de la
menace
islamique pour la ramener à des
problèmes d'ordre pédagogique C
là-dessus que je voulais vous
entendre bah
effectivement enfin tout le monde en
parle du pas de vague en fait le
problème c'est que tout le monde parle
des problèmes qui existe beaucoup en
parl en fait c'est pas qu'on soit pas
assez nombreux mais c'est que personne
les écoute à un moment donc en fait par
rapport au pas de vague effectivement
donc l'histoire de la transformation
donc d'un problème de menace islamique
par un problème pédagogique donc ça
c'est du côté du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale effectivement
cette tournure mais il également le fait
que et ça je l'ai soulevé que ça soit
donc l'intérieur ou l'éducation
nationale c'est toujours un problème de
médiatisation ils avaient terriblement
peur que ça se sache donc finalement si
on minimise un petit peu tout et si on
transforme un petit peu les événements
et ben ça ça très bien sauf qu'en fin de
compte on voit très bien qu'à l'heure
actuelle ce fonctionnement effectivement
a visé à amoindrir pour surtout pas
entraîner de réaction de la mouvance
islamique avec des problèmes de
manifestation de bruit et cetera
finalement on dessert la
cause donc ensuite il y avait une
question donc par rapport donc au prix
Samuel paatti qui est donc qui a été
mené donc par la
PSG assez rapidement après son attentat
il me semble de souvenir que c'est cé au
mois de décembre que j'ai étis en
attache donc avec la secrétaire générale
de la PHG donc qui sollicitait si un
membre de la famille ou la famille
elle-même donc était d'accord pour la
création de ce prix ce à quoi moi
personnellement j'ai j'ai dit oui où
j'étais effectivement très présente la
première année je vous avoue ne pas
m'être investi à étudier les travaux qui
avaient été faits donc par les élèves
parce que je ne suis pas professeur et
que je n'aurais pas d'aptitude je peux
trouver quelque chose de très bien et
que finalement ça serait peut-être à
côté du sujet donc je les ai toujours
laissé faire ils ont mené à la première
année des travaux extraordinaires ils
étaient pas très nombreux et l'année
d'après ils ont ouvert beaucoup plus
avec Lycée lycée professionnel donc ce
qui a emmené beaucoup plus encore mais
ils ont recruté d'autres personnes pour
mener tout ça et cette année ça a été
plus mené par avec ma sœur et mes
parents en fait voilà mais il y a un
intérêt à partir du moment où on fait
travailler les enfants sur des sujets on
les fait réfléchir c'est il y a un
intérêt c'est sûr que c'est pas ce qui
va tout changer parce que là on va
s'occuper de les emmener à réfléchir
mais ces enfants qui sont entre
guillemets
euh un peu lobotomisés qu'on leur
demande de pas réfléchir l'islam euh
politique prô entre guillemets justement
à ce qui ne n'adhère pas aux valeurs de
République à la licité c'est les travaux
qui ont été menés l'année prochaine ça
sera sur autre chose mais cette année
c'était sur les fake news mais il faut
comprendre que l'idéologie qui est
derrière en fin de compte ne et que ces
enfants reproduisent parce qu'on leur
demande de le faire il faut quand même
comprendre que c'est des enfants faut
quand même qu'on essaie de les sauver
aussi à un moment donc il faut bien que
quelque part ils aient un contre-iscours
il faut que des adultes leur proposent
autre chose que ce qu'ils ont à la
maison ou dans leur entourage c'est
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui a à l'école en
fin de compte c'est de leur donner la
chance d'avoir une autre vie donc
effectivement moi je pense que ce prix a
du sens parce que du coup ça renforce
une certaine cohésion entre les
professeurs ils se retrouvent si je sais
pas cette année peut-être plus d'une
centaine à être plusieurs professeurs à
travailler avec leur classe ils se sont
retrouvés voilà ils se sentent moins
seul en faisant ça à défaut d'avoir le
soutien d'une institution ils ont
l'impression d'avoir le soutien de quand
même quelques collègues qui pensent
comme
eux alors ensuite pour la protection
fonctionnelle alors la protection
fonctionnelle d'ailleurs je l'AV mis en
pièce jointe donc en fait elle est
accordée de façon systématique en fait
c'est juste après souvent
les agents n'arrivent pas entre
guillemets à la à la faire passer c'est
qu'en fait souvent à part il y a en fait
il y a deux limites à l'ctroit de la
protection fonctionnelle c'est quand la
faute personnelle est imputable à
l'agent c'est une faute qui qui eu au
regard à sa nature aux conditions dans
laquelle elle a été commise au objectif
poursuivi par son auteur et en fonction
d'exercé par CCI et d'une particité
gravité donc c'est ce que je reprenais
en fait le tout c'est que on peut
bénéficier de la protection seulement si
on n pas considéré coupable et à partir
du moment où mon frère lui a été
considéré comme un coupable il ne
pouvait pas l'obtenir en
fait donc pour la question de la
rapopriation donc pour la
laïcité je pense que c'est pas forcément
dans mes aptitudes de vous répondre si
effectivement ça serait
bien merci merci Madame alors nous avons
encore trois collègues et un président
qui veulent poser une question Madame
Françoise Gattel madame Alexandra borqu
fonyp madame Monique dearco et le
président la fond merci monsieur le
Président Madame comme nous tous je vous
salue avec beaucoup de respect et
d'émotion je salue votre témoignen je et
je salue aussi votre grande dignité vous
avez dit des mots qui me rappellent ce
que j'ai entendu hier dans dans un lycée
à Rennes vous avez dit perdre l'école
c'est perdre la guerre hier dans le
lycée où je participais à cet hommage au
professeur Bernard le lycée s'appelle
Émile Zola et le recteur nous rappelé
une phrase de Zola qui disait la société
sera demain ce que sera l'école et vous
avez dit ce que moi je ressens pour
voilà comme chacun d'entre nous
m'intéresser un peu à ce sujet
dramatique vous avez parlé de cet auto
censure qui est celle aussi de la
société nous conduit à nous bayonner et
à faire que nous pensons qu'en taisant
euh non enfin nous ne nions pas les
choses mais nous les effaçons
c'estbercamu qui dis ne pas nommer les
choses c'est ajouter du malheur au
malheur donc moi je voudrais vous poser
une une question et je la pose à nous
tous je pense qu'effectivement vous
l'avez dit on laisse les enseignants
porter nos valeurs que nous considérons
comme sacré ce sanctuaire qui est
l'école et sans doute est-il très vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la communauté éducative
parce que elle a peur parce qu'elle
craint elle procède par procédure plutôt
que par
affirmation de de de nos valeurs de la
société de la République et moi je suis
aussi frappé de voir comment le discours
que nous nous portons tous ici que vous
portez je ne le sens pas forcément
partagé par les jeunes générations et
que j'ai parfois l'impr effectivement
vous l'avez dit quand nous défendons la
laïcité telle que nous la prenons ils
ont l'impression que nous enfraignions
la liberté des
autres et que hier moi j'ai entendu des
jeunes dire que ils avaient compris
qu'un enseignant avait été assassiné
tragiquement mais c'était un homme qui
avait été assassiné mais que il ne
portait pas forcément la même conviction
que nous n que cet acte comme l'acte qui
a été commis à l'encontre de votre frère
était en fait une attaque massive pour
écraser notre société et les valeurs
donc ne pensez-vous pas qu'au-delà de
l'école on devrait au niveau de la
parentalité au niveau d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs et toute la société
devrait porter avec force l'affirmation
de nos valeurs et de la République et
cesser d'être aussi timide et d'AV
avancer vous l'avez dit madame je
reprends votre mot tête
baissée merci Madame Gatel madame bqu
fonp merci Madame pour je suis par là
pour vos
déclarations on ressent en tout cas
soyez-ons assurés une émotion
particulière aujourd'hui une émotion qui
va contribuer en tout cas fortement à
nos travaux et j'en suis sûr au sein
aussi de nos territoires je voudrais
commencer par regretter ceux qui qui
baissent les bras en renonçant notamment
à bâtiser notamment des établissements
scolaires on devrait au contraire à mon
sens en faire un exemple c'est ce qu'on
a fait dans les Alpes Maritimes vous
étiez présentees quand on appétisé
l'école à capdail le hall du collège de
la Fontonne et d'autres lieux et je
regrette ces comportements de de pas en
arrière je voudrais vous poser euh deux
questions la première concerne vous
quelle est la l'accompagnement qui vous
a été proposé par l'État pour votre
santé mentale et votre sécurité et
ensuite ma deuxième
question aujourd'hui vous vous exprimez
davantage publiquement et on comprend
bien ce que vous avez subi ces ces trois
dernières années selon vous en toute
honnêteté est-ce que vous pensez que
l'État est au rendez-vous en tout cas
des enjeux est à votre écoute quelle
place accorde selon vous l'état vos
déclarations à vos propositions au-delà
des échanges formels ou formel
estimez-vous en somme pouvoir réussir à
ce qui a réellement été annoncé par un
membre du gouvernement un avant et un
après Samuel Patti ou un avant et un
après Dominique Bernard je vous remercie
merci Madame madame Monique dearco je
vous remerci madame je tenais vraiment à
saluer votre courage et votre trémoyen a
été très émouvant merci surtout de ne
pas
lâcher je reviens sur des propos que
vous avez tenus vous avez évoqué le
manque de soutien des collègues et de
l'administration concernant votre frère
et même employer le terme de
paria et ensuite là vous avez également
évoqué le fait que les enseignants
collègues de votre frère ont refusé
ensuite de témoigner alors j'aimerais
savoir pour quelle raison ont-ils peur
de représaill ont-ils peur eux aussi
d'être menacés comme votre frère voilà
ma question merci madame monsieur le
Président la
fond en janvier 2022 le conseil sage
souhaitait que chaque année dans la
semaine du 16 octobre une journée
entière du temps scolaire soit soit
consacrée à à la commémoration de de la
mort de votre frère et et bien sûr à à
la transmission des valeurs de la
République à ma connaissance cette
journée n'a pas été mis en en œuvre vous
vous parliez du sondage de l'Ifop
réalisé quelques mois après en novembre
2022 dans ce
sondage les enseignants interrogés
disaient que pour 40 % d'entre eux aucun
temps d'hommage à Samuel paatti n'avait
été rendu en octobre 2022 c'est-à-dire
juste 2 ans après l'assassinat de de
votre frère est-ce que tout ça ne
traduit pas une difficulté du côté de
l'éducation nationale dans les
établissements mais mais aussi au niveau
du ministère à parler de l'assassinat de
Samuel
paatti vous avez la parole bien
sûr
alors on va reparler donc de
l'autocensure du billon alors je pense
que effectivement déjà dans ceux qui
sutoc censure il y en a une très grande
majorité qui le font par
peur mais également par un peu manque de
courage manque de connaissance aussi
parce
que pardon excusez-moi pour tous ces
jeunes professeurs je pense qu'ils ont
une formation tout à fait succinte par
rapport ort à la laicité que souvent on
les jette un petit peu dans la fausse on
leur demande de se débrouiller un peu
par eux-mêmes alors certaines fois ils
peuvent trouver appui sur des
professeurs qui qui sont déjà sur place
pour les aider les guider et autrement
il y a quelques formation ponctuelle
mais qui comme on l' déjà dit
précédemment donc sont menés par des
formateurs insp qui conduisent
effectivement à parler plus d'une
laïcité ouverte donc effectivement donc
je pense qu'effectivement il faut
totalement
réapprofondir la laïcité comme on l'a
toujours connu en France donc pour ça il
faut comme je l'ai un peu demandé c'est
reprendre la main effectivement sur
l'enseignement supérieur pour que
effectivement il y ait un système de
contrôle qui soit mis en place sur ce
qui est fait et comment cela est
fait alors autrement après donc pour ce
qui m'a été proposé en accomement
sécurité pour pour ma santé mentale donc
accompagnement
sécurité
[Musique]
personnellement je n'ai pas bénéficié de
misise sous protection quelconque
n'ayant pas eu de menace
donc effectivement faut rester tout à
fait cohérent pour la santé mentale donc
il y a le fond de garantie donc la
sécurité social qui m'offre je crois
pendant 3 ans un suivi tout à fait
régulier psycho psychiatre qui en
tellement totalement remboursé mais qui
également après déduit du fond de
garantie ce qui reste tout à fait assez
étonnant
et je vais vous dire un peu le fond de
ma pensée là tout de suite c'est que moi
j'ai été entendu par le juge
d'instruction le juge folzer à un
certain moment au cours de l'enquête
donc terroriste et faisait le point un
petit peu justement pour savoir au bout
d' 1 an comment on se sentait donc ce à
quoi il m'a demandé si effectivement
j'étais suivi ce à quoi je lui ai
répondu mot pour mot j'ai
essayé parce qu'effectivement j'avais
bien d'autres combats à mener que
d'aller à consulter donc aement le avant
le après est-ce que est-ce que les
rendez-vous les enjeux tout ça c'est bon
ben moi j'attends qu'effectivement qu'il
a un après qui ressemble à quelque chose
parce
qu'effectivement c'est un peu pour ça
que je suis venu que je suis venu
dévoiler que je veux jouer le jeu comme
tout le monde le joue c'est pas par
plaisir que je viens ici c'est pas pour
tout ça c'est que moi j'ai besoin de
vous parce que si personne ne veut rien
entendre c'est contraint et forcé
ensuite donc pour les professeurs qui
qui ont un peu refusé donc de témoigner
alors beaucoup c'était par peur par peur
que du coup ils soient eux-mêmes visés
même si en même temps je comprenais pas
mais cette fois c'était pas pas par peur
du terrorisme c'était par peur de
l'éducation nationale c'est sûr ils sont
très très méchants à l'éducation
nationale donc en fait on m'a invoqué le
devoir de réserve que s'ils se mettaient
à parler ils allaient subir des
pressions des menaces à bas bruit et
cetera c'est cette menace-l qui a
empêché que les professeurs aient
témoigné dans l'enquête contre
l'éducation nationale c'était pas par
crainte euh qui subissent une menace
islamiste non c'était par peur de
représaill avec des mutations ou bon on
va pas trop t'arranger faut pas croire
ils sont ils sont un peu perfides dans
leur fonctionnement
ensuite les sages de la léicité donc ça
tombe très bien parce que moi-même je
les ai rencontré donc je connais
parfaitement le
sujet donc effectivement ils voulaient
consacrer une journée entière
donc dédié à Samuel Patti dédié à la
laïcité dédié à la liberté d'expression
donc qui sont des principes fondamentaux
chez nous en France donc effectivement
il n'en est rien il faut dire qu'après
monsieur papendiaay est passé sur
lesessage de la laicité parce que je
m'en suis effectivement un petit peu
offusqué par voix de presse où
effectivement il les a
totalement donné l'incapacité d'agir par
eux-mêm et qui ne pourrai agir que sur
les ordres du ministre alors que je
considérais que leur indépendance qui
permettait à eux de recevoir
effectivement des remontées des
établissement sur les atteintes de la
laïcité et eux-mêmes de pouvoir agir
directement plutôt que d'attendre une
réponse du ministère qui était parfois
longue je trouvais que c'était très
intéressant donc et la dernière question
c'était quoi déjà les hommages deend
hommages donc pour la difficulté de
rendre des hommages B alors il y a la
peur on va surtout pointer la très très
grande difficulté de d'émettre les
hommages donc ça fait 3 ans qu'il est
mort 2021 2000
2023 les consignes de l'éducation
nationale envoyé au rectorat les deux
premières années ont été émis une
semaine avant la date
anniversaire cette année on a battu des
records ça a été annoncé jeudi dernier à
20h02 mê que les recteurs ont reçu pour
rendre une journée d'hommage le 16
octobre donc je vous laisse analyser
cette situation qui est rambolesque
ettant donné qu'après de toute façon et
il est vrai le rectorat avant qu'il
fasse les redescentes et que les
professeurs prennent le truc en main ça
se fait pas en 2
jours merci
madame je crois qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions nous allons donc lever cette
audition mais laissez-moi au nom du
Président de la fond et de l'ensemble
des collègues vous remercier pour votre
témoignage j'allais dire sans concession
sur la situation et qui je voudrais le
dire aux collègues parce que c'est
important me
semble-t-il nous avons avec le président
la fond hier il y avait des auditions
dans le cadre de cette mission de
professeurs
notamment certains d'entre nous étai
présents d'autres plus nombreux n'y
étaient pas mais je vous invite à revoir
cette ces audition tellement elles font
écho à ce qui vient d'être dit par
Madame Paty il y a quelques instants et
en particulier sur le point de la
solitude de l'enseignant jeose pas
parler de l'individualisme mais en tous
les cas de l'insolitude à ce la solitude
à ce stade véritablement c'est assez
éloquant et sur le point que vous avez
évoqué madame mais qui a été repris par
les autres collègues lorsque l'on nous a
dit qu'effectivement de nouvelles
générations de
professeurs n'avait pas la même lotion
de la défense de la laïcité que leurs
plus anciens collègues et on peut s'in
oger effectivement sur le fait que notre
notre laïcité telle que nous la
concevons vacille
elle vacille un peu donc nous allons
continuer notre travail les prochaines
auditions auront lieu lundi prochain je
parle sous le contrôle des de nos
administrateurs je vous invite
naturellement à les suivre nombreux car
notre travail se continue en tous les
cas merci madame de votre présence cet
après-midi au nom je le redit de tous
les collègues et je demande au
commissaire aux lois de rester encore
quelques instants merci les autres sont
libres si le président la fond le décide
naturellement
merci